[Applause]
[Music]
I know I'm so glad you're in a good mood
cuz I'm in a good mood why I'm wearing
ostrich underwear it's the best the
ostrich I do know we've been on vacation
for a month I can always tell what it's
time to come back from a vacation
because the state is on fire
that season and you know that it is 95
days until the election so clear your
calendar and the voting systems are more
insecure than the president now our
president has always been unhinged and I
had to say in the last month he did not
get more hinged juice this week he held
two of his hillbilly Nuremberg rallies
[Applause]
it's scary to people in this profession
I mean he calls the media the enemy of
the people except of course for Fox News
they're so far up his ass they're the
enema of the people
yeah from now on collusion not a crime
but journalism apparently is we we live
in a country now we're reporting reality
gets attacked because it threatens the
fantasy world created by the cult leader
so it wasn't so what's kind of good to
see a couple of days ago all our top
security people headed the FBI head of
the the Director of National
Intelligence all those dudes we're out
there saying it was Russia it's Russia
now it's happening again it's not a
drill now if we can just get the
commander-in-chief on the same page
because when Trump says no collusion he
means with his own national security
team I mean how could these people
expect to do their job when the
President himself is tweeting as he did
a couple of days ago that the Attorney
General is to stop this rigged
witch-hunt with Russia what happened - I
can't comment on an ongoing
investigation remember those days
and if you're so innocent why do we have
to stop the investigation it's a little
suspicious it's it's like when you come
home and the first thing the kids say is
the babysitter's a liar
how would I know that don't think that
deeply I'd do it anyway but look all
praise to President Trump we have to
give the good news to unemployment is
that an 18 year low however a real
biggest true economic problem is income
inequality and that's not getting better
no reason for what happened this week
someone cut one of Betsy divorces yachts
loose it's true but it's okay she has
ten yes now comes the real challenge for
Betsy DeVos subtraction you know who is
apparently going broke this was shocking
the NRA did you see this thing
a recent court filing was made public
and they are set in such grave financial
trouble they said they've already lost
all their insurance coverage and they
soon may be unable to exist they said
the only thing they own of real value is
Congress but you know but you know who
apparently was living very well this guy
Paul Manafort have you seen that the try
he was Trump's campaign manager and he's
on trial now and apparently he was
living very well he had an $18,000
karaoke machine
cashmere jeans do you have the cashmere
cashmere and the ostrich jacket worth
$15,000 he pled not guilty by reason of
MC Hammer it's an interesting defense to
in five years he spent a million dollars
just on suits this [ __ ] heard of
cocaine
but listen we're in California
California has okay well we don't a
gloat but we are the leader or the
residual do get a lot of [ __ ] people
make fun of us and [ __ ] them because we
are the
[Applause]
leader of the resistance and also
something we did a long time ago mileage
standards for cars because we are so big
we raise mileage standard and the
automakers they all had they were forced
to make their cars in line because you
can't not sell cars in a state with 40
million people
so naturally Trump now is trying to get
rid of the standards for cars and he
says it will save lives I could not make
this up he said listen to the logic if
your car gets bad mileage you'll drive
less and have less of a chance to get
into an accident yes
Trump is claiming he is doing this for
safety reasons always the number one
concern of the man who [ __ ] porn stars
without a condom
he says don't think of it as smog think
of it as a permanent Instagram filter
it's okay the last thing that I must
report to you I don't want to but this
happened this week and it was kind of a
big story I learned a new word I didn't
want to but that word is queuing on
because we saw this at the Trump rally
all the people not all the but a lot of
them wearing these to their cue cue and
we're with cue we're all cue at first I
thought oh great
Republicans have finally come to terms
with their sexuality this is a big
movement on the right side we don't hear
about these things because we're not
crazy but see cue is a person a member
of the deep state way high up in the
deep state but now he's turning on them
and he's revealing that the world is run
by a giant pedophile ring really every
president since reagan has been part of
it hillary obama who you know is a
pedophile tom hanks
steven spielberg and who's gonna stop
this Trump Trump cos who is more
qualified to stop pedophilia than the
creep he used to walk in on Miss Teen
USA pageants
he wasn't being a creep he was looking
for pedophiles
he's the circle of child molesters Trump
loved those girls like they were his own
daughter